So here on the left, this is where it
is. It says that Muhammad is talking
about one of the prophets, not all of
them, not in general, but there's one
prophet in particular that had the
situation who was beaten [clears throat]
and bruised by his own people and ended
up saying, "Oh Lord, forgive my people
for they do not know." Which prophet
said that?
>> So um
uh yes, that is true. I'm agreeing with
you. Like all I'm saying is many
prophets faced harm and cruelty from
these people. But this hadith is
teaching us about the patience and mercy
of the prophets. It's a general lesson,
not a specific story about Jesus being
crucified.
>> But it is a specific story about one
prophet, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah. I'm I'm going to continue my
point so so you could understand more.
>> No, I understand what you're saying,
brother. Trust me. Like cuz you you said
this the first time. you you know this
is a it's it's not pointing to a any p
particular situation or story but it's a
it's a lesson in general to show to
demonstrate the mercy and the
perseverance that the prophets had and
you know even showing giving you an
attitude that maybe we should have as
believers that that's your point right
>> yes
>> say that again um you kind of mute
>> yes yes I said yes I said yes
>> my it's my it's my thing hold on say say
something again
>> can you hear me
>> there we go all right that was my
speaker messing
But you say yes.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> Okay. So, yeah. So, I understand
everything you're saying, brother. Trust
me, I understand where you're coming
from. I understand your point. This is
my problem, though. My problem with your
explanation is that it's not what the
text is communicating. The text
demonstrates that there is a specific
prophet that Muhammad was talking about.
It says uh while he was speaking about
one of the prophets whose people have
beaten and wounded him and he was wiping
the blood off his face, you know, saying
Lord forgive them for they don't know.
So
>> it's talking about a specific prophet
and a specific situation and where he
uttered out a specific saying. So to say
that this isn't about somebody in
specific is a disservice to the text.
>> Yeah. Can you hear me?
>> Yeah. Yeah, I hear you.
>> Yeah. Okay. So that leads that leads us
to the question who is Muhammad talking
about?
>> So um as I said before uh you mentioned
that Jesus said father forgive them for
they not know what they do and you're
using that to prove he was crucified.
But let's let's go first. Many biblical
scholars agree this agree this verse
which is in Luke 23:34
is [snorts] not in the earliest
manuscripts. According to Bruce Mezer uh
which is a leading New Testament textual
critic, this verse was likely a later
edition meant to soften the impact of
the crucifixion story. See the text of
the New Testament Mezer which is in
1992. So it's not original to Jesus's
words. And even if he said it, it
doesn't logically prove that he was
crucified and died. The Quran explicitly
states they did not kill him nor crucify
him, but it was made to appear so to
them, which is inah 4:57.
[clears throat] So this means that
crucifixion was an illusion, not
reality. And asking for forgiveness for
one's oppressors is common among
prophets. Like for example, Moses prayed
for his people's forgiveness even when
they even when they rebelled, which is
in Exodus 32 32. And Joseph forgave his
brothers who wronged him, which is in
Genesis 50:17.
[clears throat] So it's a sign of mercy.
It's not a proof of death. So therefore,
using that phrase as proof of the
crucifixion is weak and overlooks the
bigger picture. We should follow what
the Quran and historical evidence say.
This is not just selective phrases from
manuscripts that are debated among your
among your own scholars.
>> Okay. So number one, most of the
manuscripts have this. Yes, there's a
textual variant, but most the majority
of the manuscripts have this saying. So
that doesn't mean that because it's not
in the earliest manuscript that we have
that this means that it doesn't belong.
We have a bunch of this. We have
examples where we have manuscripts that
go with what is called the majority
text. Meaning when most of the
manuscripts have a saying or a tradition
when it doesn't necessarily pop up in
the earliest manuscript we have but it's
in most of the later ones, right? Or the
ones after that. So that doesn't mean
that this never this wasn't said. The
majority of the of the manuscripts have
this while some you're right omit this
verse. So that's number one. [snorts]
Secondly, with this being said, this is
the only text that we have of a prophet
who was beaten by his people and abused
saying this. So not even Bruce Mezer,
who you're saying, doesn't believe that
this is authentic. He doesn't
[clears throat] say that this is
inauthentic. Now, when you're talking
about the saying here, Muhammad refers
to a prophet who says these words. And
the only place that we see these words
is when it's applied to Jesus on the
cross. So my question would be for you
is who else has these words in all of
history? That's a prophet who was beaten
by his people. Who else do we have that
has uh that fits this situation? Who
said these words?
>> Okay. So um this is a good question. The
idea of forgiving those who harm you is
a common theme among prophets. Again,
again, I'm I'm just going to state my
points. Uh among among many prophets,
not just Jesus, again, as I said, Moses
prayed for the forgiveness of the
Israelites even after they worshiped the
golden calf.
>> But now, he was not beaten by his
people. Please.
>> Yeah, I know. I'm just going to stay my
points real fast. I'm going to get to
your points. I'm not Trust me, I'm not
twisting. I'm going to get to your
point.
>> With all respect, with all respect, cuz
I I I have to go. and you do sound like
somebody that would that's fun to talk
to, but I I don't have much time. That's
why I'm kind of, you know, pressing on
this. I need this to be handled
directly. If you can, I need We're not
talking about prophets who generally ask
for forgiveness for their people. We're
talking about something specific.
Specifically, this prophet was beaten by
his own people, wounded, bleeding, and
asked for the the Lord to forgive them
for they do not know what they're doing.
That's the statement. So, please, where
do we find this? If it's not Jesus, if
this is inauthentic to Jesus, who else
is this applied to specifically, please?
>> So, as I said, Wait, can you guys hear
me?
>> Yeah, we can hear you.
>> Hello.
>> Yes. No, sir. We we can hear you, bro.
>> Hello. Wait.
>> Testing testing testing testing. We can
hear you, man.
>> Can you hear me now?
>> Yeah, we can hear you.
>> Yo.
>> Ah, he's losing connection, guys.
>> Hello,
>> sir. Can you hear us? Can you hear me?
>> I'm just going to switch to another
connection. Wait,
>> it's all right, man. If if this doesn't
work, it's okay. We can probably talk
about this another time.
>> Can you hear me now?
>> Can you hear me?
>> Yeah. Yeah, I'm here. I'm here, bro.
>> Okay. I was I was just wrapping it up,
man. But look,
>> I mean, if you want, I can come back
tomorrow if you will open a live. I I'll
be I'll be live Wednesday. I'll be live
Wednesday, same time. Okay. Um if you
show up, I'll definitely make you
priority. Okay.
>> Okay. Okay. Thank you. Thank you.
>> Yeah. All right. Take care of yourself.
>> Take care. Take care. Thank you.
>> Yeah. Guys, there's no answer for this.
And Islam has no foundation. Islam has
no foundation. Islam has uh especially
when it's disconnected from the prophets
is disconnected from uh the apostles is
disconnected from the scriptures. So
because of this Muslims do not know how
to deal with such a hadith. So I've had
it up for a very long time. I want you
guys to screenshot it or save it. Keep
it. Here it is again. Just in case you
guys, you know, just in case you guys
haven't done that yet, here it is on the
left. Keep that in your pocket. And ask
your Muslim friends about this. Ask your
Muslim neighbors about this. Who is this
prophet that was beaten and wounded by
his own people, bleeding from his head,
and said, "Oh Lord, forgive them.
Forgive my people for they do not know."
And show them the gospel verse. Show it
to them. There is no answer. All right,
that being said, I love you guys, man. I
love you all. I hope that you guys
learned. I hope this strengthened you.
Shout out to our brand new sister,
Aisha, our sister in the faith. She made
sure that she came back to the stream to
uh give glory to God and make it known
with a very loud voice that she
denounced Islam, denounced Muhammad as a
false prophet, and accepted the Lord
Jesus as her Lord and Savior,
surrendered to him and to the father and
the spirit as the one true God. Glory to
God for that sister for the boldness to
come up on the panel uh living in a
Muslim country and announcing with
boldness and courage her faith in the
Lord. Man, nothing but the Holy Spirit.
And let's continue to pray for uh
Samantha. She's still, you know, hanging
on to Islam a bit, but she keeps coming
back. She's seeking, she's learning,
she's studying, she's asking questions.
So, let's continue to pray for uh
Amanda.